hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast I'm
checking in on you just check how are
you Oh [ __ ] a bullet Billie is back
and he's feeling better than ever no
more coffin fits no more night sweats no
more sleeping under a mosquito net with
my [ __ ] malaria
I don't think malaria is a funny
reference considering each year 42
percent of women on the planet suffer
from this well the men are giving
endless supplies of nyquil well here's
something I started to talk about the
other day on one of my podcasts one of
my many rambling nonsensical whatever
the [ __ ] you say podcasts out here in
Los Angeles Hollywood specifically
there's a group of people that want to
get the Hollywood sign taken down
because they live near the Hollywood
sign and there's too many [ __ ]
tourists I just don't like that has got
to be one of the most [ __ ] up things
I've ever heard in my life like the
whole city has to suffer you know well
you take down this iconic sign because
you were dumb enough to buy a house next
to a tourist attraction you [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait why don't you just buy a
house across from the [ __ ] Magic
Castle whatever the [ __ ] they call it
down there at Disneyland and then get
upset you know we need to shut down
Disneyland
there's too many people walking around
with like Mickey Mouse ears on it's
almost like I bought a house right
across from [ __ ] Disneyland I could
see if it was a new like since you
bought the house that you know all of a
sudden they
this new [ __ ] thing up and you're
like whoa whoa hey hey hey wait a minute
this was a quiet neighborhood when I
bought the house that's why I bought the
house and all of a sudden there's all
these [ __ ] people people of it that
[ __ ] sign it's like 80 something
years old right the [ __ ] sign is
probably as old as your house I don't
know what the problem is let me look
this up here Hollywood sign history
you'll still be called Hollywood land
back of the day yeah it was Hollywood
land I mean I think actually think that
the Native Americans put it up if I'm
not it might probably said something
else like Hiawatha or some Native
American [ __ ] is that actually Native
American shooters that some white
Hollywood [ __ ] the history of the
Hollywood sign a sign born in 98 1923
that [ __ ] thing has been around and
then some [ __ ] with a house that was
built in [ __ ] 1978 that they just
bought in 2016 wants the [ __ ] thing
taken down all right nobody gives a [ __ ]
about the history of the sign I'll wave
maybe people do all right
signs almost a hundred years old it's
fitting that the Hollywood sign the
worldwide symbol of the entertainment
industry was conceived as an outdoor ad
campaign for a suburban housing
development called Hollywood land after
all despite the high profile of the film
biz real estate has always been
Hollywood's primary economic driver
although the signs what the [ __ ] no one
hasn't you needed the entertainment
industry so it could make so they could
afford all these [ __ ] houses who the
[ __ ] would move out here just to live
into a in a [ __ ] house with all of
this traffic all right although the
signs appearance of purpose has evolved
over the years its basic it's
aspirational message remains the same
this is the place where magic is
possible where dreams can come true and
these [ __ ] people that live near this
side want to take this down huh back
then the dream was beautiful was a
beautiful home in lifestyle today the
signs promised is more subtle
can only be described as the parade of
images desires and ideas can conjured by
the word Hollywood I think they're
[ __ ] looking into this a little bit
too much no Hollywood you come out here
because you want to [ __ ] star in
movies or write movies a direct them you
know then it take advantage of your
position of power act like an animal and
then have the whole [ __ ] thing come
crumbling down I mean that's that's
that's what that's what's been going on
since we've been out here take down
Hollywood sign Search sees the Hollywood
sign okay Christine O'Brien has decided
I guess nobody in LA should get to look
at that [ __ ] awesome sign anymore
alright there's a woman who wants to get
rid of the Hollywood sign I can't blame
the impulse it looks so good
attacked by tornadoes and aliens what
there's such a rash such a rush in the
slow Creek and the quick crunch of the
corrugated letters peel from the
scaffolding and fly off from Mountain
whoa the [ __ ] wrote all is [ __ ] the
worldwide fame of the sign is bolted to
that image of just of its destruction
hey Christine O'Brien those suggest
taking the sign down and moving it to
Universal Studios on the other side of
the hill erecting the context lists H
that some sort of tourist trap in the
flats of Hollywood she lives in the
signs original namesake Hollywood land
the sign once read Hollywood land does
that mean her house is where land used
to be this person I have a really smart
are this English a second language she
lives in the science original namesake
does that mean she lives in Hollywood a
small steep disorienting neighborhood
where big houses hug the streets in
front and hang off into nothing in the
back hollywood lands nests of streets
rise out from the top of beach with
jaysus this [ __ ] verbose [ __ ]
all right the strangest thing about the
Hollywood sign is that everyone led a
huge real-estate advertisement slowly
rot on one of the city's most prominent
peaks for 55 years from when it was
planted on the hillside by Hollywood
land Realty company in 1923 until it was
dug up and replaced in 1978 slowly
accruing meaning and sentiment over the
same decades Los Angeles was earning its
reputation as a place that was happy to
demolish its own brief pass dude is this
the weirdest right person writing ever
it's like it's just like contradicts
itself I can't even read this [ __ ] all
right let's let me just go back here
Hollywood sign hiking to the sign
Hollywood sign Hollywood sign knocked
down here's the best way Hollywood sign
trail closure is long overdue
hang on a second here I'm sorry this is
just all [ __ ] interesting to me I got
somebody with this selfie stick that's
not really that's not a good argument
for the other side I just don't get
people that [ __ ] bought houses up
there like what did you think was gonna
[ __ ] happen and like how much money
do you [ __ ] have and how much of a
[ __ ] are you just move it to the other
side
I actually think to be honest with you
the fact that someone will want to take
that sign down is a clear example of the
density of the disappearing middle class
they don't want these animals going up
there these lower-class people walking
around they have [ __ ] goddamn walled
off house all right why is it long
overdue it was a great hike all right in
the span of about 10 minutes so-and-so
can hike from a paved road in the
Hollywood Hills Beachwood Canyon
neighborhood to take a breathtaking view
of breadth of Griffith Park the city
skyline and of course the Hollywood sign
when I have the free time I always like
to come here nobody gives a [ __ ] but
after this weekend she will lose her
quick-quick escape to urban life
starting Tuesday the Beachwood Drive
gate will be closed to public because of
court action hikers and tourists will be
directed away from the trail entrance
the soon to be closed trailhead is
popular among Angelenos as well as
tourists wanting a selfie with the
world's most famous sign some residents
welcomed the closure even though they
along with other visitors will no longer
be able to access the trail hook it's
long overdue says Jim Krantz 60 stop
again like he didn't go up there and he
[ __ ] 23 skidoo with some [ __ ]
chick back in the day and now you're too
[ __ ] old legs are too old to go up
the trail so everyone else can't go now
everybody grab my [ __ ] shocked by gap
he did that back in the [ __ ] well
that would make him too old the Vietnam
era I don't know
okay gate walking through I I'm always
walking my dog we come up here every
night we're going to miss our little
hikes up here still while the closure is
a bummer it's worth that he said there's
a classic [ __ ] la guy 60 years old
still saying bummer would you interview
the [ __ ] dude I prefer to have it
locked and lose all the people and all
the noise and all the sound and all of
the litter and everything else that goes
along with it it's not a legal challenge
by residents but one from the sunset
ranch a horse Stabler and tour company
okay so it's the horse people that is
putting an end to public access to the
Trail Road all right [ __ ] it I don't
know what I'm talking about I thought it
was the people with the houses no it
turns out it's a [ __ ] rancher it's a
matter although selfie people are
spooking your horses it's not what's
going on tonight just waste ten minutes
talking about that [ __ ] sign why Bill
why did you waste ten minutes because
your [ __ ] team lost again last night
yes they the finesse Bruins the
goalscoring Bruins once again lost to
the the pretending to be tough Tampa Bay
Lightning I've been watching the pros
for forty years it's been a long time
since I've seen us get pushed around the
way we're getting pushed around and
we got too many Rick Middleton's and not
enough Jay Miller's we need we need
somebody I don't know we just letting
people waltz into the [ __ ] zone and I
kind of feel like after the first two
games in Toronto Toronto made an
adjustment and kind of showed how to
beat the Bruins and I think we caught
Tampa a little flat because of their
layoff and we beat him in Game one and
they're basically just doing the same
[ __ ] thing that Toronto did to us
which is you know but kind of a one line
team right now I don't know maybe we
just had a couple of games that were bad
but it's not the Tampa scoring goals
it's that they're [ __ ] all this face
washing and all this [ __ ] that they're
doing and now they're starting to
[ __ ] act like they're this tough team
and then not I mean I could beat up half
the people around Tampa that's a true
story [ __ ] with you I know it's just
weird I've never seen the Bruins not
saying it's happening a lot it's happy
they've just taken a little too many
[ __ ] liberties and the calls haven't
been going our way the last two games so
I got to feel like we do this game you
know I don't want to sit there and [ __ ]
about the officiating because some
nights you get the call some nights you
don't and it's just been kind of
back-to-back you I don't know how you
miss a stick hitting an eight-foot guy
in the face I don't know how you missed
that and then you turn around and call a
penalty on his retaliation and you know
I don't know I don't know it's been they
but generally speaking I don't think the
officiating I think I don't know if
they're overthinking things it's just
been weird not as much bad just kind of
weird officiating so maybe who knows
tonight we're dude up next tomorrow
night maybe I guess we play we're due to
get some calls however I will say this
the rebuild has been a success the fact
we already won a [ __ ] playoff series
and we could win this one we can
actually get to the Eastern Conference
Finals as quickly after blowing up the
team so I am happy about that I just
wish we would have we had a little more
teeth you know I
Tampa I don't look at tamp they don't
have any giant [ __ ] goon they're
basically a bunch of gold scores and a
couple of [ __ ] punks and I don't know
I don't know what the [ __ ] deal is
I'd like to see nationally use his size
a little more and [ __ ] lay somebody
out even if you gotta take a pen is that
is that game gone now in hockey I mean
we had our first fight last night
[ __ ] unheard of [ __ ] ten games in
to the playoffs we had our first fight
but you know all these people that
watched Olympic hockey this is the
hockey that they wanted so they can now
sit down and watch it which they're not
doing the [ __ ] you know I think the
people that tried to get fighting out of
hockey are also people that want to take
the Hollywood sign down those kinds of
people oh by the way you guys keep
asking me about this Michelle wolf thing
I haven't seen it I don't pay attention
to the news but evidently she did the
White House Correspondents Dinner and
everybody's all up in arms because she
told some jokes which I can totally
understand
I mean she's telling jokes people well
that's that's how [ __ ] dangerous is
that you know it's just unbelievable to
me that it's okay to genetically alter
our food supply that's okay you can take
all the [ __ ] principles of heroin and
create them in the synthetic form and
create a [ __ ] nationwide heroin
epidemic that's fine not a word from CNN
a [ __ ] fox on that [ __ ] not a [ __ ]
peep right you can totally cook the
economy leave millions of Americans
upside down in their own [ __ ] houses
the rest of their life they're gonna owe
more than what their house is worth and
then you give the houses right back to
the bankers so they can do it all over
again all of that is fine all of that is
fine but evidently if you're a comedian
and you tell some [ __ ] jokes people
are going to debate it for 10 [ __ ]
days while they're feeding kid their own
[ __ ] kids
this poison food that's gonna make you a
nine-year-old have a [ __ ] mustache
it's [ __ ]
that'sa gonna drop before he learns how
to ride a bike it's so full of [ __ ]
hormones and all this other [ __ ] [ __ ]
evidently that is fine poisoning your
own food supply something Isis jerks off
to doing to us I mean are those not
terrorist acts against your own [ __ ]
people the people that did that [ __ ]
should literally be hanging from their
toes but this not not a [ __ ] word is
said about it because they advertised on
CNN and Fox and they donate to [ __ ]
politicians so they don't say a [ __ ]
word you know all of these [ __ ]
presidents they leave the office worth
tens of millions of dollars despite the
fact that they only made 500 grand a
year as president you tell me how that
math works out why isn't that ever
talked about the level that they do now
when a comedian tells a [ __ ] joke
it's ridiculous I'm off my soapbox jesus
[ __ ] christ
I've now this is just this is literally
the era of just getting outraged about
something that really doesn't [ __ ]
matter well meanwhile two feet away
there's a raging [ __ ] inferno can you
believe that joke she told at that
[ __ ] place where she was hired to
tell jokes can you believe she went in
there and did her [ __ ] job that my
god that's outrageous
let's talk about that for ten days and
ignored the fact that the Ford Motor
Company is phasing out cars because no
one buys them anymore because everybody
needs an SUV because their cars are full
of [ __ ] that they don't need that
they're eventually gonna take down to
Goodwill and is gonna end up in the
[ __ ] ocean and that swirl of [ __ ]
trash did you hear that Caitlyn Jenner
joke did you hear what so-and-so said
about Donald Trump this is why I don't
watch the news this is why I just sit
alone by myself and think things and
agree with them and then spew them out
as though they're fact I mean why not
why can't I have my own little news
network why can't I behave like CNN and
Fox and curate my [ __ ] news and
my own [ __ ] angle on it and then just
have Americans yelling at each other I
don't know I don't understand why people
like this the level of mouth-breathing
[ __ ] you have to be to be on Facebook
right now screaming at somebody about
politics or social issues you know and
even worse the people that totally buy
into it and then start using all that
[ __ ] corporate speak like that was
micro aggressive you know walking around
like you're this informed person they
can all go suck a dick good for her she
went there and told some jokes and she
ruffles some feathers good for her all
right
they now they're gonna treat her like
she's in [ __ ] Isis classic classic
journalism in the modern era all right I
got a couple of so that's what I think
about that okay I don't need to [ __ ]
watch any of the jokes I know she's
[ __ ] hilarious and I know that it's
completely blown out of proportion and
everybody's running around like [ __ ]
chicken little people with blue ties
yelling at people with red [ __ ] ties
or the blue tie people like it cuz the
red tie people got it worse or vice
versa
alright plowing ahead here meanwhile
there's gonna be a [ __ ] polar bear
swimming up to my [ __ ] house in about
three years
alright put your box everybody bought
your box delivers healthy 100% grass-fed
and finished B free-range organic
chicken a heritage heritage bread pork
which is the purebred pigs swine that
came over here from Europe okay not the
bastardized ones that we have here that
are all all mixed up alright these are
pure pigs to your door on a monthly
basis you know it's funny that they do
that with dogs and pigs you know what I
mean it's like if you like took out dog
and pig and you actually put human being
in there you'd sound like a grand dragon
all their products are human humane
humanely humanely raised and never given
the antibiotics or hormones I got to
tell you something man I've been eating
that stuff all week it's delicious
absolutely delicious
high-quality hell
the protein you can trust unbelievable
taste there's a huge difference in taste
between animals raised on pasture and
those fed grain and concentrated animal
feeding operations yeah that's the
difference between cool kids and people
with helicopter parents butcher box
actually probably sound a good example
parents that love them versus parents
that abuse them but at the end of the
day they do kill the animals so I don't
think there's a lot of love there
butcher box is changing that and they
offer free shipping anywhere in the
lower 48
I like how they said in the 48 states I
mean do I get to pick which 48 Alaska in
Hawaii the middle children of our states
they never do they just never feel like
they get their due because they're not
connected to us you know what do you
think what happens someday if Alaska
Hawaii in Puerto Rico all got together
and decided to take on Blackwater now
that's a [ __ ] movie I would like to
see offer $20 $20 off plus free bacon
you get $20 off and free bacon by going
to butcher box.com slash burn and using
the discount code Burpee URR I have the
hiccups now from talking about food
Express VPN Victor Papa November
Facebook has been in the news a lot
lately getting thrashed for letting
third parties get your user data but do
you really think they're the only ones
doing it now I don't I don't because I
just got some spam from some [ __ ]
incorporation that I have and the only
people that had it was the bank so the
bank obviously sold it to some other
constant now getting this [ __ ]
pamphlet asking me if I want to take a
[ __ ] trip to I don't know ponderous
internet providers like Verizon and
spectrum can record a list of every wipe
website you visit and they can legally
give it to anyone it's time to stop
trusting big corporate
with your data and start protecting it
with the expressvpn with expressvpn you
can privately and securely surf the
internet without being tracked by anyone
setup on all of your devices only takes
a few minutes the Express VPN app runs
seamlessly in the background of your
desktop laptop and smartphone or tablet
your network data is encrypted and IP
address mask
keeping your activity and identity
completely private well what if somebody
hacks into your system for less than
seven dollars a month you can be
protected first with expressvpn but at
least you're putting up a fight you know
this is like prison now you know you
just don't want to be the easy target
and they'll move on to somebody else
every expressvpn plan is covered by a
risk free I'm gonna sign up for this
[ __ ] 30-day money-back guarantee after
you've experienced the freedom privacy
and safety that expressvpn gives you're
never going to want to use the internet
again without it to take back your
internet privacy today and find out how
you can get three months for free go to
expressvpn com / / that's e XP are ESS
VPN Beco x-ray Papa Romeo echo Sierra
Sierra Victor Papa November com / bar
for three months for free protect your
internet and data with expressvpn today
you know if politicians weren't strictly
driven by money you know you'd be able
to go you should be able to go and sue
everybody that put all your [ __ ]
information out there you know what I
mean I don't know they need to have like
they need to have stricter rules on
hacking information you know what I mean
we got to act like the way they do in
like Southeast Asia
when bankers step out of line they put
them to death you know I'm not saying we
got to kill these [ __ ] people but
like did you know we could bring back
the stockade right now you can't do that
we'd be like we would sit there and be
like well what does that make us we
can't do things like that we're not
supposed to be like that
we just waterboard people water boredom
doesn't water it waterboarding sounds
that sounds like a [ __ ] it sounds
like a game that you a toy that you
would have before like the [ __ ]
internet nel a cool [ __ ] came along you
know remember all that bed those awful
the [ __ ] games that we had at least
we got outside we weren't fat [ __ ] do
you guys remember trackball see if I
could find that commercial it was like
basically I think we actually bought
that trackball commercial see if I can
find this thing trackball by whammo oh
my god this takes me back this takes me
blam oh whatever happened to those guys
the Internet video games ah this is
somebody [ __ ] playing trackball I
want the [ __ ] commercial you know I
don't understand these people that like
you know their kids about ready to bump
their head and rather than preventing it
they let them do it so they can [ __ ]
get a youtube video out of it 20
pictures that Hillary Clinton wish
wishes would go away that's what I look
up trackball and then that's what I get
the night Ted Nugent this is how you
guys can I'm gonna I'm gonna give up my
information here by the videos that just
came up here you guys will understand
what I look for on YouTube alright
Michaelangelo 2018 rock and roll Led
Zeppelin tribute the night Ted Nugent
challenged Leonard Skynyrd Jonathan
Moffat plays Michael Jackson's Billie
Jean he's a drummer 20 pictures that
Hillary Clinton wishes would go away
family never believed their grandpas
crazy stories until and there's a
picture of an old trunk the dragon takes
its toll in blood this is a motorcycle
video I do watch people wipeout on
motorcycles you guys do that [ __ ] I
don't like watching like knockouts I
used to like watching
[ __ ] but there's just too many [ __ ]
sucker punches and [ __ ] like that but I
do like watching these [ __ ] people on
motorcycles driving like goddamn
lunatics I like when they run from the
cops and they get away and I like watch
it and wipeout I don't know what that
says about me brutal motorcycle crashes
part three part three four million eight
hundred thousand [ __ ] video look at
this guy out BAM he was going too fast
he rode right into the fat guy and the
fat guy didn't even fall down now the
guy the guy doing the front [ __ ] this
is my favorite one you know when they do
the front wheelie and at some point you
have to let go and do the faceplant dude
I swear to god people on motorcycle
there's a level of balls there's a lot
of fat guys on motorcycles right now you
know that has to affect the center of
gravity of the bike it's got to bring it
up higher right that's probably why this
guy just went down here's another guy
going into a turn everything's going
good there's snow on the ground what
could go wrong this is the last one I'll
do because I know this is getting boring
here anything I can do to avoid talking
about how miserable I was watching the
last two [ __ ] Bruins games what's
gonna happen is a deer gonna come
running out this guy seems to be riding
very responsibly he's checking out all
the beautiful areas is he gonna hit get
hit by a Santa Claus sleigh oh we hit
the ice and he goes down wow that sucks
what the [ __ ] were you thinking here's a
guy in a truck as a smart guy why don't
more people go out to a track there's no
branches or [ __ ] SUVs out there all
right I'm done with that [ __ ] speaking
of which I got to get my truck tuned up
get that [ __ ] ready for the summer out
here get that [ __ ] ready for the
summer off
oh by the way I'm having a very special
guest coming out to the podcast next
week very special guest to promote their
new show Barry on HBO it's going down
next week a very special guest will be
coming on to my repeat very special
guest so you can look forward to that I
have a weakest shows coming up out in
San Francisco Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday there was another show
that I was announced on some sort of
benefit I saw on Twitter I don't even
know what the [ __ ] that is my agent
called me up asking me if I knew what
the [ __ ] it was nobody knew what the
[ __ ] it was I'm not going to be doing
that benefit
why would I schedule an a competing show
and a [ __ ] alright Christ I gotta
call this person back all right well
listen that that was the Thursday
[ __ ] podcast Jesus Christ you know
something I literally flit early phoned
this one in I spent ten minutes talking
about a [ __ ] sign that I thought the
neighbors were bitching about it turned
out it was a [ __ ] horse farm was it
anything accomplished I defended
Michelle wolf okay how about that
without ever seeing what the [ __ ] she
said I don't even give a [ __ ] you told
jokes it's like getting mad at a plumber
because they came over to your house and
and and plumbed you get offended by the
way they snake out a [ __ ] toilet I
think that's all I did really is that
all I did well you know what do you want
from me you know what school was seeing
Pedro Martinez at the Bruins game I wish
the Bruins and I mean Boston teams would
do that more
you know our legends just like disappear
you need to have him come back around
and talk to the younger people about the
[ __ ] even if it's from another sport
it's still great just to see a champion
there was Bobby Orr and Pedro Martinez
but like I always bothers me at Larry
Bird like he just like left you never
see the guy come back but you know he
was always like that right he always
wanted to go back to the country and
just be left alone
you know you know there's a bunch of
billboards a couple billboards out here
these fans put up asking LeBron to come
out here I mean that's how hard people
go out here it's how much money they got
you know they can just pay for
billboards all these [ __ ] wine and
ass Laker fans cuz they've been bad for
a couple years it's all they [ __ ]
threw out here it drives me nuts
you know it's just the Celtics can't
compete with it
I've been saying this for years this is
our pitch eight do you want to come to
racist Boston and deal with the winner
in [ __ ] sixes or do you want to go to
racist Los Angeles where it's summer
everyday and [ __ ] movie stars and in in
supermodels we can't compete with that I
don't think there's one infinity pool in
Massachusetts all right I got some [ __ ]
to do
that's the podcast go Bruins go Celtics
Celtics game two against the 76ers mo
cheeks Andrew Tony huh those are the
Sixers I remember I'm gonna be watching
that tonight
actually no I'm gonna be editing f is
for family and then I'm gonna go to a
spot somewhere possibly all right that's
it listen to the music and enjoy another
half hour of some Thursday afternoon
podcasts from earlier this year or maybe
one from years ago I have no idea have a
great weekend you [ __ ] I'll see on
Monday
my
[Music]
sweet Leilani heavenly flower
tropic skies are jealous Mars Asia
I think they're jealous
tell us because you're hey what's going
on it's bill burr and it is the Monday
morning podcast for Monday May 3rd 2010
how the hell are you I got some great
news for you the podcast is back it is
back up on iTunes and right now you're
gonna go to iTunes and you're probably
not going to be able to find it because
it's it's gonna take three to six days
for it to actually appear if you go to
search it because iTunes is a pain in
the ass as we've noticed over the last
three months but my new my new sort of
web guy here is been able to fix the
thing and basically if you want to find
all the podcasts since the beginning in
2007 right up until now all you have to
do is just go into iTunes and once
you're in iTunes you click on advanced
and it once you click on advanced what
you do to down click on subscribe to
podcast and then this little window will
open up and this is what you type in all
right
type in WWB bird comm slash podcast and
hit OK and you know that'll be it you'll
be in you'll have all the podcasts from
here on out until the end of time unless
something happens to me because this is
my podcast thing whatever the [ __ ] it is
I'm not with the G cast anymore
I'm not with that libsyn [ __ ] I'm with
my own thing so I don't have to deal
with their fees I don't have to deal
with them suddenly going out of business
or switching the way that they do things
or their intellectual properties or
their [ __ ] whatever the hell it is
that they're doing and this is why it
took me so long and I just want to thank
everybody I appreciate the patience I
even appreciate the angry emails people
sent me like dude what the [ __ ]
is going on I appreciate all of that
because that meant you give a [ __ ] and
that you like to listen to it so once
again go into iTunes and least on a Mac
if you click on advanced the window that
opens up the second thing down will say
subscribe to the podcast you open that
up a window will open and in it you will
write w w bilberry comm slash podcast
alright and it's the regular slash the
one that starts further to the right and
then comes to I don't even know no I
don't even don't even try to describe it
back slash I don't even [ __ ] know how
to tell you that so that's it and one
other thing I have to hype is we have a
fan page now here on the Bill burr
Monday morning podcast and that one is
WWE capital m capital M capital P and
then your spelling podcast
I'm the worst WWE mm podcast calm and mm
in the P of podcast to capitalize that's
how so go on there
leave your comments if you want to check
out some pictures of some of the [ __ ]
up references that I'll make to whatever
podcast you're listening to they'll be
up there I actually ask you guys some
questions on there I haven't done that
in a couple weeks but finally everything
should be up and running and that was
probably the driest most unfunny three
minutes and 25 seconds I've ever done on
the podcast but I had to get that
information out there I'm gonna send out
a mass email and I'm gonna put it up on
Facebook and on myspace all that
information that I just gave you and if
you know other podcast listeners if you
want to email that what I just said
email it to them and maybe I can maybe I
can build it back up again you know it's
kind of like a something that went out
of business and then they was kinda like
the Jay Leno Show I went away for a
minute now I'm back and I'm trying to
get my ratings back again granted I I
didn't kick out some unsuspecting
redhead I kicked myself out and I am an
unsuspecting redhead
and speaking of redheads god damnit am i
good with the [ __ ] segways somebody
sent me something this week they sent me
a video
and they were like why don't you say
that like Dave Attell a video somebody
sent me a video and said you gotta check
this thing out or whatever I don't know
if you've seen this yet but there is a
video on YouTube you guys familiar with
the artist m.i.a
she did that song I believe is it Paper
Planes you know it's that song you
couldn't [ __ ] get away from last year
what was like an awesome song and then
every filmmaker in America seemed to
fall in love with it and put it in their
movie or even set like pineapple express
it wasn't even in the movie but they
still put it in the trailer all right I
like paper and I like planes and I like
something and I'm [ __ ] lame maybe
something man you something man you
something yes bill we know huh there's
this one there's a bet cover this my
cover of mi a's paper planes what I know
it's not called paper planes it's called
something else something with paper in
it you know so anyway she has a new
video out that somebody brought to my
attention and I hear the relaxed
confidence of my voice now I feel so
much better now that I know my podcast
is back up on iTunes even though for
three six days most of you will not know
that because you won't be able to find
it because you won't have heard this
anyways so somebody sent me this thing
this this video mi a has a new video
called born free all right so they
should yo check this video out and it's
actually a video my girlfriend already
showed me she goes I want you to see
this okay just watch it with an open
mind I don't want you to criticize it
just watch it okay can you do me Nikki
just promise me that you're not gonna go
oh gee just two seconds into it can you
please so I said yeah fine I'll sit down
and I watch it and it's basically I'm
not - whatever I'm gonna ruin it here
all right spoiler alert basically the
video is about it's not really army guys
but it's more like sort of riot police
guys white dudes I think all white dudes
and like riot police and they're they
bust into this
I'm a building that looks like it's in
the Middle East it's got that Middle
East sort of vibe to it which basically
means you know there's some bullet holes
with some sand in the background to me
that's the Middle East you know could be
Miami I don't [ __ ] know right so I'm
watching this thing and they basically
they just go through this of this
apartment complex just horrific Lee
kicking in doors violating everybody's
rights they don't give a [ __ ] what
people are doing because they're looking
for this one dude and they find the dude
and they grab the guy right there's
redheaded white dude sort of a buzz cut
I guess and they grab him he doesn't
want to go and then fighting him and
they bring him downstairs and then they
put him on a bus and he gets on the bus
and it's a whole bunch of other redheads
it's a whole it's a whole bus full of
redheads all right and right there I was
like oh Jesus but I didn't say anything
because I promised my lovely girlfriend
I'd watch the whole thing so long story
short they drive him to a camp they have
him get off the bus and then they make
him run so that all the police can
basically kill him and they have them
run through minefields and all that type
of [ __ ] and it's basically commenting on
the racial profiling the genocide and
some of the stuff that has gone on in
the past and is gone evidently going on
right now all right it made no
references to Iraq but it definitely had
a Iraq sort of feel to it except it was
redheads so in the end my girl was like
well what did you ain't like these
redheads they're [ __ ] arms are flying
off all right they're beating him with
clubs they're doing all this horrific
[ __ ] to him to this sea of redheads and
she said what did you think and this is
basic and I'm also answering this person
who sent it to me what I thought of it I
thought it was a great idea for a video
and I thought it could have made a good
point if they didn't pick the singled
out group of redheads for the simple
fact that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
redheads
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're just I don't know what it is
people don't they they just don't care
about us you know remember when Kanye
West was saying you know George Bush
doesn't care about black people well
nobody cares about white people so you
know at least somebody cares about black
people it's just George George doesn't
you know but there's this people who do
that was my thing the second they
decided redheads it just became a comedy
and I gotta admit it was weird because
I've never seen a busload of redheads it
dawned on me I've never seen that like
I've seen a busload of like you know
generally speaking look on a bus it's a
bunch of people with brown hair the
occasional blonde right and you know
maybe a redhead every five buses
there'll be one redhead but an entire
busload of redheads was funny to me and
also he also it was oddly disturbing it
was they were weird looking and I
realized in that moment even as a
redhead I'm gonna love those
weird-looking sons of [ __ ] and I
realized that this is the deal with
redheads we are not the main course we
are a spice we are the spice in like I
don't know we're like red pepper flakes
that you put on like I don't know a
steak or something if you ordered
something in a restaurant and all they
brought over was the spice you'd be like
dude what the [ __ ] was the meal that's
what that's what what redheads do that's
our job with people you go to a baseball
game and you're just sitting there going
Jesus Christ how many [ __ ] brunettes
can I look at vamp there's a redhead oh
[ __ ] there's a redhead right reset your
brain and he can we'll look at some more
brunettes now that's what we do so long
story short that's what I thought I
thought about the video I thought it was
a just because they don't know who else
they could have picked I understand what
they're saying what if they rounded up
this certain segment of white people
would you give a [ __ ] now you know I
guess you know as always I don't know I
don't [ __ ] know but like because it
was redheads
I just felt at that point the second
they started running through
minefield they should have had they
should have had like Benny Hill music
way man I could and danton's they blew
him up cuz it just was funny to me and
weird it was oddly like if you were
walking down the street and all of a
sudden like just a group of redheads was
just walking the other way you can't
tell me that you wouldn't be creeped out
or uncomfortable just for the mere fact
that you've never seen it seemed like
those are my [ __ ] people and I saw
them all together and I was weirded out
by it am i a self-hating redhead I don't
think I am I just I don't know so check
it out it's called you want to see a
bunch of redheads get to get beat up and
blown up there you go I mean [ __ ]
South Park did that [ __ ] where woods
kick a ginger day and kids actually did
it they actually went out and [ __ ]
did it you couldn't have that about any
other group without some sort of outrage
you know flick some Jewish guy's balls
day you can never have that to be there
be considered anti-semitic and be taken
off the [ __ ] air if you said
something my black people you know
redheads I don't know we fall into those
weird cracks where we're white dudes so
no one gives a [ __ ] but uh are we a
silent minority I snoop it's about that
how redheads are portrayed in the in
movies you know whenever the cool guy we
never are we're always the friend with a
guy in the van
you know when Tom Cruise is in there
going you know I'm like sitting there in
a van and a laptop he's he's running
around with like [ __ ] Halle Berry or
some other aunjanue
you gotta give me more time and then I'm
in the band huh I'll try you know no
clicking away on my laptop that's what
I'm doing no [ __ ] no sunshine no [ __ ]
okay since the beginning of filmmaking
huh Opie Richie Cunningham Howdy Doody
David Caruso was our only [ __ ] shot
and he blew it he [ __ ] I just talk
about this [ __ ] on stage he [ __ ] blew
it so I mean I don't know it's just how
we're Eric Stoltz came close he came
close but then he did the movie mask and
once again reminded everybody that he
was genetically compromised
um what else has there been one even
like Shaun White the baddest snowboard
in the world would they call him the
flying tomato yeah thanks thanks thanks
thanks for that dead [ __ ] a horrific
[ __ ] nickname
there's no goddamn respect you know and
Here I am a redhead myself and I watched
that video and I thought it was funny we
thought it'd be funny remember that Joe
Piscopo when he used to do Allen Funt we
thought it'd be funny all right so let's
plow ahead here that's what I thought
about that [ __ ] I did a lot of TV
watching this week but I'm gonna try to
get back to some of the topics here on
the podcast oh here's a little story for
you I was gonna tell you
I forgot I've actually already recorded
this podcast I recorded it last night
but I was tired and I was grumpy I was
in a bad mood cuz I had another incident
with my downstairs neighbor the
continuing story of the downstairs
[ __ ] neighbor and for those of you
who are new to my podcast I have a
neighbor downstairs classic you know old
guy and we have hardwood floors and he
thinks we make entirely too much noise
any [ __ ] hates us so but I confronted
the guy and so he doesn't yell at us
anymore and yesterday I was hanging out
and I was doing what most people of my
age do 41 years old what do you do
you're helping out your wife you taking
the kids to the park [ __ ] no you're not
even married you don't have kids you
know what you're doing you just you're
taking your LP for those about to rock
that you just bought and you're putting
it on your turntable because you know
that angus is always in the right
speaker and malcolm is always in the
left and you want to learn the rhythm
too evil walks that's all I wanted to do
people I wasn't hurting anybody all
right
and then for underrated overrated very
underrated ac/dc album is the for those
about to rock the problem was is they
would have following the back and black
album but if there's any guitar players
out there you got to [ __ ] listen to
the the b-side of that album all right
evil walks EOD
they'll hold the whole backside I love
him turning remember what the last song
is on that one mmm
I can't do nothing right spellbound
that's another great one and it's just I
don't know I it's still the craziest
thing where now that I've started
playing guitar is I am finding a whole
nother genius-level to ac/dc music that
I've now been listening to for 30
[ __ ] years if you can believe it
Malcolm is an apt in Angus they're
[ __ ] geniuses so this is all I want
to do is you know I'm never gonna be
able to go who knows maybe if I play
till I'm 65 I'll actually be able to
play a couple of Angus leads if I stick
with it but like I just want that's why
I started playing guitars like I just
want to be able to play the [ __ ] that
Malcolm plays just the rhythm underneath
right so that's all I'm doing I'm
sitting there with my [ __ ] my
phonograph my record player my stereo
whatever you want to call it and I'm
getting ready to switch the balance all
the way over to the left so I can figure
out what what Malcolm is doing what the
[ __ ] doesn't Malcolm do that makes you
if you had in the last row of the
[ __ ] Roman Colosseum he's still
blowing you out of the back of the thing
you know it's all about not playing the
high E with those guys they're [ __ ]
maniacs anyways so this is what I want
to do so I switch it over to the left
side and I find out my left side
speakers [ __ ] up oh my god Jesus
Christ so I'm trying to fix the thing
and as I reach behind it I got this
little I don't know what is you plug the
speaker into this little it's like the
size of like a matchbox car right and I
knock it out and it hits the floor boom
hits the floor I was like I literally
made that face like you know cuz I don't
want to piss off the [ __ ] bear
downstairs right so he doesn't yell at
us anymore you know what this douchebag
does he gets up don't don't don't don't
go my hair I'm walking over to his door
and he opens up his door and then slams
it as hard as he can and I really wish
that I was mature enough as as an adult
to just laugh that off but it made me so
[ __ ] mad because I really feel like
this is like the that I'm walking around
on egg shell
my own goddamn apartment you know here I
Drive drop one [ __ ] thing all day and
I let it go like oh my god what did I do
I'm literally on eggshells because you
know and and this is what always happens
to me I always get on eggshells around
people initially that's my initial
reaction when someone's a dick is I kind
of back off a little bit you know and
then I then I always go in to wait a
minute well you really tiptoeing around
or whatever the [ __ ] it is I'm doing and
then I get mad and so that's what
happened with that guy and it's just
it's just like I don't know how to solve
this it's an old guy I can't yell at him
I just can't
it goes against how I was brought up
it's common decency he's an old son of a
[ __ ] whatever he's [ __ ] miserable
but he keeps doing this this [ __ ]
alpha male [ __ ] well you slamming the
door like like I don't know if I'm wrong
to read it that way like like what do
you think is some sort of [ __ ] badass
remember that commercial well you want
to dance old man you want to [ __ ]
dance that's what I feel like doing walk
it up in ass why can't I open these
goddamn blinds probably gonna be upset
with the noise I just made there
there you go move the screen every week
there we go now it's open
now it's open yeah so I was dealing with
that [ __ ] guy so anyway so I did a
podcast last night and just the the
anger I had for that guy was just
running through the entire thing and I
was like who wants to listen to one
angry son of a [ __ ] and I know what
you're thinking bill you know that's how
I think he's funniest when you get mad
it was a different kind of mad it was
like a serious like dude why don't you
just [ __ ] get over it kind of mad so
so anyways oh here's the history story I
wanted to tell you I had a gay little
moment yesterday at a I was hanging out
with my girlfriend you know you ever had
one of those moments you know you have I
was uh driving back from somewhere Oh a
vegetarian restaurant that my girlfriend
wanted to go to she's like you want to
go to you want to go to Eddy cucumbers
and I'm like no but I told her I'd take
her out to breakfast and then it became
lunch and that she wants to go to this
[ __ ] vegan place right you know where
they have like you know this chef should
literally come out and be like okay who
likes impressions alright this is my
impression of bacon
he just wheels out some brown soy that
he that he [ __ ] that's all it is it's
it's a bunch of it's soy soy is like the
rich little of a vegan restaurant where
it can [ __ ] imitate it everybody but
not quite it's more like rich little in
the 80s when he stopped working on his
impressions and he was still like
nightly doing like an impression of like
lyndon b johnson it's like dude we're
already up to the [ __ ] first george
bush which were not aware of yet that it
is the first george bush unless we're
marty mcfly so anyways here we go there
we [ __ ] eat there and we're driving
back she goes i want to get some ice
cream you wanna get some ice cream i
know a great ice cream place i said [ __ ]
yeah i love ice cream i love it i like
to eat ice cream you know and i'm not
ashamed of it i know you know who
doesn't like ice cream you know maybe
people who are lactose intolerant maybe
they don't like it people who who didn't
floss throughout their life so it hurts
their teeth you know there's one for you
youngsters brush and floss every night
because if you don't some day ice cream
is gonna hurt your teeth and you'll
never be able to enjoy it again you know
someday you'll have full upper and lower
dentures sitting there just [ __ ]
doing that thing you know you know
people chew when they have dentures they
do that thing where it's they look like
they're trying to blow a bubble with
their food for some reason that tongue
has to stick out like a goddamn llama
you don't want to do that [ __ ] so
anyways i'm like yeah let's go so why am
i walking around i don't know why i'm
walking around what the fly am i
questioning it i felt like walking
around I'm walking around so anyways so
we go to this this ice-cream place and
of course it's not like the old school
ones that I used to go to like
friendlies and Brigham's where you just
walked in and it was like you know what
do you want you want chocolate you want
vanilla he wants strawberry you know
rocky road they had a couple those in a
like rocky road I don't like
marshmallows I really don't they just
did [ __ ] gross they did just I don't
know usually when something's cool it
makes it good like melted cheese but
this marshmallows are [ __ ] disgusting
you know oh you douche bags out there
making s'mores I don't what the [ __ ]
wrong with you but anyways so we go to
that we go to this you go to this place
and we walk in it's one of these places
now they have all these new [ __ ] I
don't know what kind of flavors they got
I was gonna say funky flavors and I
realized that I shouldn't use that word
so I had to go back to [ __ ] and I was
like should I say it should I not say it
[ __ ] flavors they had like red velvet
cake ice cream I mean it doesn't even
make sense anymore so they had another
one that was like you know caramel
something and it had great nuts on the
top of them right so this is the deal I
don't have you never been really
designer ice cream places but what they
do is their flavors are so [ __ ] up
you've never had them before so you got
you want to try them out so how it works
is they scoop a little bit out with that
look this little plastic spoon and then
they Hannity and then you eat it yeah I
like that one let me try this once my
girlfriend's doing that and it says dude
scoop in the ice cream out so it's like
already it's just like weird like which
one you want to try and even like the
names oh let me let me try the triple
foofy [ __ ] one right so I go let me
try the great nut one right so we scoops
a little bit out and then he goes to he
goes to because they hand it to me and
the spoon is so small this dislike
there's no way for me to take it from
without brushing my hand against his
hand you know and then I also I have to
take it in a very very like delicate way
because I don't want to spill the ice
cream so my hand grazes his hand you
know like we're in lady in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] eating spaghetti in a hand kind
of way right and I take it from him and
then I eat the ice cream and it just it
just there was something about it that
just felt wrong okay I just sort of it
was intimate
I had an intimate moment with his hand
in my hand and then I put a sweet treat
into my mouth afterwards and told him it
was good
[Laughter]
so is the best part so I don't give a
[ __ ] what that ice cream was felt like I
was like I'm taking that [ __ ] right now
let me let me get that flavor because I
don't know if I can do that again and
you know I don't know
only they start blushing or ask for your
phone number I don't know what's gonna
happen so the best part was after I go
yeah let me just get that grape nut
flavor my girl goes oh no you get two
scoops two different flavors what other
one you want to try and I'm like that
one the one right next to it I don't
think they go well together I don't give
a [ __ ] can we end this where's that
cowboy movie with the two gay cowboys in
the Brokeback Mountain moment with the
ice cream we just ended oh god I'm
getting creeped out right now
but I'll tell you something else [ __ ]
it was worth it man ice cream is
unbelievable with the grape nuts on it
telling you it's worth it it's worth
grazing another man's hands just to try
it
it's [ __ ] phenomenal so they go that
was mine that was my little moment and
the ice cream was so good I'm gonna go
there again and I'm gonna try my best to
get a female the next time I have to do
that that might get dangerous right then
what a [ __ ] no I don't do sex jokes
okay they're too [ __ ] easy all right
I just trashed Jesus all right so that
was my gay little moment of the week I
can't get [ __ ] comfortable why can't
I I can't I'm standing up I'm sitting
back down my foot feels a lot better by
the way I want to thank the D I had a
couple of doctors who actually listened
to this or at least they say they are
and whoever was the one who told me to
take a bottle of water and freeze it in
the fridge and roll that underneath the
arch of my foot it's done [ __ ]
wonders so pass that on if you ever [ __ ]
up the arch of your foot and every time
you go to take a step and it feels like
this there's there's an invisible smurf
just stabbed in the bottom of your foot
just do a bunch of calf stretches almost
like runner stretches is what you do and
then like like three four times a day
just roll a frozen bottle of water
underneath your arch it's like you're
massaging it and
icing it all at the same time and I
gotta tell you want to talk about a
[ __ ] ice cream headache take a frozen
bottle of water and stick it on the
bottom of your foot but you know you get
used to it you get [ __ ] used to it so
I want to thank whoever whoever told me
to do that I somehow lost the email with
all my web stuff this week but anyways
plowing ahead Here I am I have more
exciting news right now I am currently
getting ready to do my fifth performance
on the David Letterman program number
five my fifth time gonna go out there
and do some stand-up and I'm putting
together the set right now I'm very
confident I think everything's going
good it's ahead of schedule and tonight
I'm literally gonna sit down and before
I go out I have it all worked out and I
just have to type it out like my jokes
are easily I can take the curse words
out easily because so much of my cursing
is not even necessary I just like to do
it and then because I love getting the
emails like so much your cursing you
don't even need it those [ __ ] people
who sit there and they think that clean
comedy is like this unbelievable thing
like how do you do it I just don't
understand it you know it's I'm not
saying it's it's it's a bad thing but
the way people like that that right
there that's a pure that's pure [ __ ] you
know what that that's like watching
Lawrence welcome because they're just so
wholesome that you just think that none
of those guys in that band or racist you
know you know people who watch clean
comedy and then just think see right
there that's what Tommy's like and those
are the same people who like their
neighbour ends up being a serial killer
right and they always say the same [ __ ]
he was so nice like what is your
definition of nice because they say
hello to you every morning good morning
how are you nice weather we're having
he's so nice CEO he says hello he's re
never curses it's wholesome its
wholesome comedy you know
get [ __ ] Hugh Grant could you get any
more wholesome than that guy Hugh Grant
killed the hooker seen on sunset I
learned that when he got busted
they used to be hookers walking up and
down the street back in the [ __ ]
heyday but because that guy didn't even
have the decency to pull down the
[ __ ] side street the guy's got one
blowing him as he goes into in-and-out
burger you know but you look at his
movies and he plays this bumbling oh
he's out there banging hookers so all
you [ __ ] I'm sick of it you're idiots
you're idiots your your your your basis
for somebody being nice is they say nice
things you know have you taken any
psychology classes have you ever I don't
know what tried to break somebody down
and figure out why they do this [ __ ]
that they do why am i yelling at all of
you guys like you disagreed with me
obviously you don't give a [ __ ] if I
curse if you listen to this thing you
know what I did right I should have been
playing Catholic Church music right
underneath that that's what I was doing
right there I was guilting you guys
about something you didn't even [ __ ]
do what an [ __ ] I apologize so
anyways that's that's typical me I had
great news and then I have to go
negative way with it yeah so I'm gonna
be taping on Monday May 16th and then I
believe it airs that Friday which is May
20th so set your DVRs and all that type
of stuff and I'm gonna go out there and
have a great time so there is that and
another big piece of news for the
trifecta here is I finally have a date
in Las Vegas that's right
after years of people asking me on the
podcast dude why don't you come to Vegas
what's the deal man
Tom Papa who is the host of the marriage
ref very funny show on NBC everybody
should watch good friend of mine Tom
papa wholesome Tom papa does not curse
in his act you know granted he's
murdered half his [ __ ] neighbors but
Nutkin
he that he hosts a show at the Orleans
casino in Las Vegas okay so just go to I
have all the information up on my web
bilberry calm but it's not gonna have my
name on it because it's Tom show I'm
coming on and I'm basically doing the
Tom Papa comedy show so if you see Tom
papa why don't I give you the [ __ ]
dates and stop running my goddamn mouth
I'm very excited about this date because
a huge fan of Tom papa good friend of
mine and I don't get to work with a lot
of my friends anymore because they're
all headlining so there's a rare time
that I get to work with another comedian
that I respect and I'm friends with okay
so it's on June 25th and 26th it's a
Friday night and one of the cool things
about the Orleans casino it's the last
place where George Carlin did stand-up
see that a lot of people didn't know
that did they you didn't did you
so uh there's that and that that ends
that now what the [ __ ] that I want to
talk about I just had a great segue
there and I couldn't remember what the
hell I was gonna talk about Jesus Christ
this always happens whenever I rerecord
these things I have these moments I have
these little lulls and I've learned to
not panic during them let's talk about a
show that I saw an ESPN called
30 for 30 it's this great new segment if
you're a sports fan set your DVR and
check this [ __ ] out
they're doing stories on who killed the
USFL the United States Football League
which I didn't I didn't know somebody
killed it I just thought it didn't work
out you know I actually a lot of people
don't know this I actually went to a
USFL game I saw the Boston Breakers
first the Washington Federals had
Nickerson Field in in Boston
Massachusetts in the Boston Breakers one
and it was almost a capacity crowd just
out of curiosity and I still remember a
lot of the teams Philadelphia stars and
New Jersey generals owned by Donald
Trump had Herschel Walker and Doug
Flutie remember that [ __ ] Michigan
Panthers won at the first year Bobby a
bear is that who was the quarterback
with then went and played with the
Saints believe it or not I'm not looking
this [ __ ] up on the Internet I actually
remember this stuff and my favorite
[ __ ] helmet
I thought the Michigan Panthers had a
cool helmet but I liked
Oakland they had like that that fist
holding the lightning bolt on that
yellow helmet was the [ __ ] and I thought
it was very fitting because the Raiders
have the best uniforms in all football
and everyone's tried to rip them off
whenever your team becomes too [ __ ]
like they always go well let's [ __ ]
steal the Raiders school start wearing
black cuz that's a badass color remember
jerry glanville huh speaking of
marshmallows that Doughboy remember that
when nobody respected the Houston Oilers
all of a sudden he gets a black satin
[ __ ] Houston Oilers jacket I know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about so
anyway so I watched one episode of it I
can't recommend it high enough I watched
one on the University of Miami called
the U and it was talking about the
heyday of the University of Miami it was
[ __ ] awesome man it was just an
awesome thing on so many different
levels just showing how badass that team
were was how crazy that team was and
then also just watching all those old
guys now exaggerating all their [ __ ]
stories was hilarious and that's the
great thing about being an old guy if
you did something at eight when you
retell the story you did it at fifteen
and they were doing it to such a
ridiculous level that I almost forgot
that I was alive when that [ __ ] was
going down because it sounded like a
brand new story to me I mean granted
they were not liked throughout college
football and college sports in general
without a doubt they were considered
crass no class thugs all that
abso-fucking-lutely but to tell the way
they tell this story it's it's just like
and the president was like [ __ ] Russia
what's going on at the University of
Miami I mean was a at the end of the day
it's a [ __ ] football team it's
hilarious this one guy goes we were like
alley talking trash oh yeah you were
just like golly you know he basically
brought talk and [ __ ] to a whole nother
artform he basically was the first guy
to do it not even on a national he did
it on a global level and he was also
stripped of his title because he
wouldn't go to war because of religious
reasons and he stuck by it and you guys
grabbed you dicks after catching
touchdown passes oh yeah that's the same
thing you he would just like it you know
what it's like it always goes back to
that same quote when I see that that
Bill Russell clip Bill Russell was
talking about his philosophies on
rebounding I knew what the guy I broke
the guy down I buh buh buh and then he's
just like so a lot of times I got the
rebound before the guy ever even took
the shot you know
Rayleigh bill really you could it wasn't
it really that you was six foot ten and
everybody else was a five foot eight
inch [ __ ] white guy at that point
other than Wilt Chamberlain who was you
know didn't everybody look like Bob
Cousy
you know but he's an old man now so he
get he gets to [ __ ] and he gets to
exaggerate like look at Pau Gasol when
they won Game one the other night no no
when they when they closed it out sorry
when they closed it out against Oklahoma
when when Kobe missed that uh he misses
that shot and then pow you know caught
the rebound and all the one motion put
it in I can't wait I mean it's like he's
gonna tell it to me I would love to hear
him tell it later on in life he's gonna
be like you know I mean did you see the
look on his face he couldn't even
believe it he was like oh my god Kobe's
finally not gonna yell at me on the jet
ride home I did something good I did
something good he didn't even know what
to do it was like when Phil Mickelson
finally won the Masters and he jumped up
in the air and then landed on the ground
and cuz he felt weird like he didn't he
didn't know what to do he didn't know
what to do but later on in life when
that [ __ ] old fish heads
maybe when his head finally [ __ ]
fills out and it's round like I had
supposed to be rather than looking like
the Sunday paper turned sideways god
help me if that guy ever sees me I
really forget that just because NBA
players can throw him around that I am
only 5 foot 10 inches and he can [ __ ]
throw me through an Applebees wall
upside down anyways yeah when he goes to
tell that story it's gonna be [ __ ]
hilarious
he was just it was a moment in the game
and I knew something had to happen you
know and when he let that ball go I knew
it wasn't gonna go in and something told
me I don't know where that ball is gonna
come off the rim
I'm gonna be there you know he's gonna
tell it like that that's what if you're
like me if you're in your early 40s and
you were around when the University of
Miami was winning all those titles dude
the way that they talk you would have
thought the entire country was was just
quaking in the corner because of a
[ __ ] football it was a football team
was hilarious you know especially being
a guy from Boston which is not a college
sports town we're a professional sports
town all right so all we know about the
University of Miami is that the [ __ ]
BC Eagles beat you on the last play of
the game
that's your badass team [ __ ] 65-yard
goddamn prayer
Tom Jackson says knock it down and you
didn't you let your art failings sneak
in behind you how does that happen how
does a [ __ ] little white dude get
behind all those black guys on defense
it's it's physically impossible
white guys can't do [ __ ] like that um so
anyways but definitely watch it because
the the guy who keeps raining it in his
Michael Irvin cuz Michael Irvin is just
really [ __ ] honest because at one
point they were saying you know the
media was biased they will race this you
know which obviously you know there's
tremendous element from amount of truth
to that they were saying that while they
were cutting two stories of these guys
bringing guns to clubs you know and then
they finally cut to Michael Irvin and
Michael Irvin was hilarious he was just
like you know a lot of guys say that the
media was biased but now that truth is
we were we were a bunch of bad kids we
were bad kids so you know you can't
[ __ ] argue with the honesty all right
let's get into the topics here I know I
said it all right YouTube videos for
this week if you sit an edgy cubicle
right your boss has been a [ __ ] today
and you feel like [ __ ] it off you know
sticking it to the man here's a couple
for you to watch two quick ones [ __ ] you
Baltimore that's a great one parody of a
car commercial and there's another one
if you're a sports fan you know like the
new thing when you go to a game like the
insane like flat-screen TV like they
make some sort of intro for your team to
get the crowd psyched up like like picks
like the like maybe like the Nashville
Predators how they have like that save
- tiger maybe I'll just have like a you
know computerized saber-toothed tiger
doing some [ __ ] with like a hockey stick
or whatever I got the best one ever
that is so [ __ ] politically incorrect
you guys ever wondered what a
computerized polar bear would look like
if it decided to blow up the world and
actually it actually blows up the world
if the planet Earth gets blown up by
this psycho [ __ ] polar bear it's the
it's the new nuke hockey opening 2010
that's what you want to search and then
no nuke is na n okay hockey opening 2010
it starts with a boat and ice breaking
boat you know obviously it's an Alaskan
team I'm guessing with no nuke
unless it's I don't know the Yukon
Territories I have no idea and there's a
polar bear frozen in the ice and it
because they break up the ice the polar
bear gets mad comes up through the ice
it's ten times bigger than the [ __ ]
boat I'll just tell you the beginning
and then some sort of supernatural [ __ ]
happens where it's collapse its hands
together like Michael Clarke Duncan
Duncan in that movie about death row in
the mouse right and all of a sudden it
has like a hockey stick that's glowing
like a lightsaber the thing lets out a
growl and then slams it down on the ice
breaking ship breaks it in half and the
[ __ ] thing sinks and the first thing
I'm thinking was well what about the
people on the boat right
isn't that what they'd say at the arena
I think it's good that there's a teddy
bear but does it have to kill people on
a boat this thing that that's just where
this starts I don't know what happens
after that next thing you know it's in
an f-16 and the [ __ ] planet Earth
blows up this is for the beginning of a
hockey game it's the greatest one I've
ever seen if you're into that type of
[ __ ] so check it out the nuke hop hockey
opening 2010 alright let's get on with
the questions for this week ask Bill
this is a very interesting question and
I think I might need a little bit help
on this one because this goes outside
the realms of what I've been doing with
my life bill I've been meaning to ask
you
I'm afraid that when I'm an adult and
have responsibility that I will not be
able to smoke weed I'm not a pothead I
smoke about a few times a week more in
the summer I get decent grades at a
decent school
I feel like professional and family life
won't allow me to blaze anymore this is
what I love about this is right up until
then right up until he says the word
blaze I'm really I'm really believing
this guy you know whatever you know I
smoked a couple joints a week you know I
do well in school a great school you
know I'm very responsible I don't drink
and drive him a couple times a week I
have if he said I have a couple of talks
no big deal I get it you know you want
to watch Laverne and Shirley you need
fiddle-faddle I don't have a problem
with that you know but once you say
blaze I'm just that's at least isn't
that like blunt level cuz I always just
I mean I'm not pothead I don't even
smoke this [ __ ] so I just picture blaze
meaning that there has to be some sort
of significant source of fire to get
that joint going like it's that big
maybe I'm wrong cuz I'm a boozehound so
anyways he goes do you think this is
true do you think anyone do you know
anyone your age or older who do smoke
decent grades at a different a decent
school okay do you know anyone your age
or older who do smoke all right
the this is my feelings on on weed I
don't think it's that bad especially
nowadays we can get like a vaporizer
check that out or go to the mmm what is
it WWWE MMP podcast calm and they'll
have a picture for you I guarantee it a
vaporizer is basically if you put the
weed in there you light it on fire or
whatever the [ __ ] you do and it
basically filters out everything except
what gets you high now that has to be
way more healthier than sitting down and
finish in a six pack isn't it I guess it
depends if you get the munchies and then
you go out and eat cake and ice cream I
have no [ __ ] idea but anyways I think
yeah I think you know I know people who
are married and have kids and you know
if you once in a while they go out send
their kids to bed have a couple of puffs
but you know you know kids they'll
figure out what
you're doing that's the only thing you
have to really hide it because I don't
think I would smoke weed in front of my
kids ever because even though I don't
think it's any worse than having a beer
it isn't it really isn't the thing is is
you are knowingly breaking the law and
it is considered like you know you're on
drugs for for some reason alcohol isn't
which is complete [ __ ] but it is so
you just do that in front of a kid and
you know kids they always want to outdo
you they see you drinking a six-pack
they're gonna try to go for you know at
least eight to 12 I don't know so I
would just be worried this is with no
psychological you know psychology
background or any of that [ __ ] I would
just think if you if your kids saw you
smoking weed that he would be smoking
weed by at least 7th or 8th grade maybe
10th if he was a [ __ ] nerd at that
point but and then I don't think it
would be that big a leap to coke I
really wouldn't now I know pot heads
this is like a [ __ ] big thing with
you guys well that's just [ __ ] it's
such [ __ ] dude don't prove it's a
[ __ ] gateway drug really I think it
is because everybody I know went that
route you started off with booze then
you went to weed then you went to coke
and whatever else so you are weed you
went to coke or they had crank anybody
remember that [ __ ] um whatever else you
did took pills whatever you did you're
just like whatever acid but you always
went weed first I mean as far as I know
that's how people who I didn't hang out
with in high school did it look at me
still being a [ __ ] friend not
throwing anybody under the bus
oh dude speaking of that I'm back back
in my hometown this weekend really
excited Thursday and Friday
I'm at the Wilbur theater Friday night
he's already sold out
Thursday night tickets are still
available go to billboard.com click on
the Wilbur theater for a Thursday May
6th for tickets I'm really whoring
myself out this week and yeah and I'll
be in Atlantic City on Saturday night
doing the Trump Taj Mahal anyways so
yeah that's my answer I think yeah you
can easily continue to
we'd just be open and honest with the
person that you're with and just say
look you know I don't smoke at every
[ __ ] day I just would rather do that
then have like 12 beers and become a fat
[ __ ] you know so that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna buy a I don't even know
what what the what the quantity is if
you smoke twice a week what would you
need how much would you need would you
need a couple of buds would that get you
through it I don't know just a couple of
buds a month that's all that's all I'm
gonna do sweetheart
all right don't look at me that way okay
I'm a smart guy I went to a smart school
and you know do you know anyone your age
or older who do smoke um all right
that's it
that is it for that let's move on to the
next thing uh what do we got here hey
Bill it's been about two weeks since the
April 19th podcast when you said you
wanted the listeners to ask you the
following question if I happen to be a
comedian what are the general rules if I
am opening for the headlining act all
right yeah I did not have a good time
that weekend so yeah this is what you
would want to do you just go up and do
your act within the allotted time you're
given if somebody tells you to do 25
minutes do 25 minutes and do your act if
you want to blow me off the stage go up
there and absolutely [ __ ] destroy
with your jokes if you want to try to
make it hard on me as a comedian if you
want the club owner to be looking at you
going like this guy's gonna headline
someday that's the way you do it you go
up there you do your act and you [ __ ]
destroy and you make it hard for me all
right that's the ideal okay now there's
other there's there's some headliners
out there that tell like you're
basically another thing as courtesy to
the closing act is you're not overly
dirty and you don't play with the crowd
that's another that's another thing you
know there's other people they say don't
go in the greenroom you know some people
who was like [ __ ] divas they don't
want anybody in there
or they're tired and then there's other
headliners who won't even let you sell
[ __ ] you know sometimes feature acts
come up to me like I have yo-yos can I
sell my yo-yos some headliners don't you
let you do that
so this is my [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
how dirty you are cuz I'm filthy I don't
give a [ __ ] you can talk to the crowd I
don't give a [ __ ] you can come in the
greenroom you can sell your [ __ ]
afterwards I don't give a [ __ ] just do
your time just stick to your [ __ ]
time all right don't go up there and do
when you're supposed to do 20 do 40
minutes and say oh hey sorry about that
and then I say okay that's cool whatever
we all do that every once in a while and
then the next night on The Late Show you
do 37 minutes and you're talking to the
crowd and you're saying mean [ __ ] to
them and you're not really killing but
you're not bombing you just you know if
this is a technique that some features
do to try to make the headliner look bad
is they go over their time and they [ __ ]
with the crowd and they're overly dirty
or they'll say mean stuff and it's
basically they're blowing out the
parameters of the show and then they're
also they're making the crowd tired you
know and so then when you go up as the
headlining act rather than having a
crowd that's ready to go
they're already worn out you're coming
up there and the energy is like you've
already been up there for a [ __ ] half
an hour that's like how tired they are
and that was basically the scenario that
I was in there's this guy did 40 and
then he did 37 and then when I said dude
what the [ __ ] that's just that's two out
of three shows he then hit me with the
brilliant Oh how much time do you want
me to do you know which is like an open
mic question this guy was actually older
than I was okay you know the club told
you how much time to do so either you're
deliberately trying to make it difficult
on me
by boring the [ __ ] out of this crowd for
an extra twenty [ __ ] this guy was
supposed to do 20 minutes he did 40 he's
doing twice his time yeah it was one of
those deals either that or I don't know
what your deal is I don't know I was not
able to figure this guy out it was
actually a sad thing cuz he was a smart
guy and he had good jokes and he should
have just done him and even like
Saturday night that he goes up there and
then he did he did like 14 minutes and I
was just beside my said now I got a
cover and
115 rather than just doing his 20
minutes and I go up there you know and I
do my hour hour and 10 now he's up there
for you know like 12 minutes of some
[ __ ] so now I got to cover the rest of
it and it's it's I just wanted to be
like dude what is your problem
you know what you don't have a watch you
know you've been doing this [ __ ] long
enough I know you headline I know you
know what it's like when somebody does
that amount of time in front of you so I
don't know I just basically after after
he said what did he say how much time do
you want me to do I just basically
stopped talking to him for the rest of
the weekend because you know it's just
like I can't explain only like when
somebody asks a question and when what
they're really saying is I think you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's basically what he
was saying I think you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you're gonna be three shows
into the weekend and the comedy club
never told you how much time to do in
front of the headlining act you know and
you never asked in three shows in you
don't know where the light is and you
already went over on the first show when
you apologized for it and then then you
[ __ ] do it again and it's like yeah
that's either you're a [ __ ] or you just
don't give a [ __ ] and this guy was not
dumb so either he didn't give a [ __ ] or
he was doing it on purpose which is how
I took it I took it like this guy's
doing this on purpose to make me look
like an [ __ ]
but fortunately I'm a [ __ ] beast and
I had no problem following the guy but
it was just [ __ ] I didn't I felt
like I was going on up after like a
[ __ ] telethon and for all you young
comics out there I know you know it's a
stupid [ __ ] thing to do because I
actually would have said nice things
about the guy cuz he had good jokes and
but I also you know I'm not gonna go
badmouth him be honest with you I don't
even remember his [ __ ] name you know
I don't even remember his [ __ ] name
so that's it so that was my weekend
that's what I was dealing with I was
staying there and this guy was going
over and he was like wha you mean you
don't like a bucket of [ __ ] dumped over
your head before you go up what Oh
didn't know that I've only been doing it
for 20 [ __ ] years I have no I I what
are the rules do you just keep going
until you feel like you want to get out
what how do you feature for somebody I
have no idea I've just been doing
stand-up
since [ __ ] Rita Rudner was an open
mic er I don't know anything it was
[ __ ] ridiculous and whatever whatever
and I just felt like yeah why don't I
tell the whole story I felt like it like
somebody at the club should have said
something to the [ __ ] guy they after
the second time you know and nobody did
and then I'm put in a position like do I
go to the club owner like a like a
[ __ ] girl and tell on the guy so I
decided to say something to him you know
and then he hit me with that [ __ ] how
much time do you want me to do gee I
don't know you've been in this business
20 years was the last time you heard
somebody go yeah do 37 in front of me do
37 and be sure to piss off as many
people in the crowd as possible before I
go up there that would be awesome and if
there's somebody drunk in the crowd by
all means just keep going back and forth
with them and turn it into an absolute
[ __ ] fest before I go up there that
would be great and if you could go do
twice the amount of time that they told
you to do and act like you have no
[ __ ] idea that would that yeah that's
what I want that's what I'm looking for
I'm sure that that's what you're looking
for when you go out and headline all
right I got a little upset there so that
was my experience so there you go that's
what you're supposed to do all right you
know just go up there and do your
[ __ ] act and if you're killing the
guy after you cannot follow you he'll
have no reason to complain because you
didn't [ __ ] with the crowd you weren't
dirty you just did your [ __ ] and he
couldn't follow you that's the deal
all right so we're gonna end with this
one somebody asked me a hypothetical
question that I think this is a new
topic here hypotheticals a little
hypothetical for you if something
happened to your dog and she needs an
operation that's gonna cost 50 grand but
there's only a 65% chance that she'll
survive the operation do you pay
abso-fucking-lutely
absolutely I pay twice that absolutely
65% absolutely put my mortgage down on
that she's a [ __ ] pit bull she's a
warrior
you know that's my buddy absolutely come
on you know you know my dog my dog might
do a lot of things but you know what it
wouldn't do it wouldn't go up and do 37
minutes in front of me it wouldn't okay
because there's a loyalty to a pit bull
that that son of a [ __ ] didn't have
when I was out there all right oh [ __ ] I
ran out of time you know what I forgot
to do I forgot to do the whole the whole
bad covers the worst coverage you've
ever heard I got I got I got a break out
that list next week duh you guys are
sending me some great ones one that I
can remember off the top of my head was
was when earth wind fire did it did a
cover of Paul McCartney I think he was
with the Beatles that got to get you
into my life and it was a song that when
the Beatles did it or Paul McCartney I
forget it was a great song you know and
when Earth Wind & Fire did it they
somehow turned it into this smooth jazz
sort of you hear the song and you start
moving your head like those dudes a
night at the Roxbury it's just it's one
of the worst the harmonies uh got to get
you into my life but up but up up but
it's [ __ ] horrible and it's no excuse
cuz it's a big it's like [ __ ] like 27
black guys weren't Earth Wind & Fire you
would think one of them would be like
hey this kind of sucks you know how the
hell did we pull this off this sounds
like somebody white did a cover of this
that's how [ __ ] awful it was alright
anyway so that was the that's a podcast
for this week sorry if it was a little
bit late this week but once again all
you have to do if you want to get the
podcast is you know what you have to do
listen to the beginning of this podcast
goddamn it I've already told you you go
to iTunes click on advanced this is on a
Mac you go down scroll to down to the
subscribed podcast then you type in
www.interfight.net and I'll talk to you
next week when I'm out in Boston all
right
heavenly I dream no paradise hold my
sleeve you are my paradise co-leaders
lovely Leila
you are my dream
[Music]
you are my paradise complete a lovely
Leilani you are my dream
[Music]
you